اجسادنا تتكيف مع سيناريوهات الحميه لذلك
تتوقف عن حرق الكثير من السعرات عند اتباع
نظام غذائي صارم بشكل مستمر للحفاظ على
الطاقه تناول كميات اقل من الطعام ثمن
الحصول على المزيد من السعرات لينقص وزنك
استراتيجيه الحميه العكسيه تعمل على خداع
الجسم حتى يشعر بالامان الكافي للحفاظ على
حرق الدهون الزائده بمعدل مرتفع الحميه
العكسيه تعتمد على تناول نصف السعرات
الحراريه التي تحصل عليها عاده لفتره من
الوقت ثم رفع معدل استهلاك السعرات
الحراريه بمقدار 50 الى 100 سعر حراري في
الاسبوع ولا استمرار حتى عشره اسابيع بحد
اقصى هذا النظام قد يساعد في تسريع حرق
الدهون والحفاظ على معدل انقاص الوزن بشكل
ثابت تقريبا ما يمنع الاصابه بالاحباط عند
راغبي التخسيس اخيرا توصلت دراسه نشرت في
الدوريه الدوليه للسمنه ان التناوب بين
الايام ذات السعرات الحراريه العاليه
والمنخفضه يمكن ان يقلل من خطر الاص ابه
بمرض السكري وزياده حرق الدهون البطن
بنسبه تصل الى 60%
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات